hey guys it's Alanna and I'm heading to
the Pokemon video game championship
series today which is on in Brisbane so
I thought that I would bring you guys
with me on my iPhone so Nintendo have
been travelling around to all of the
major cities in Australia and hosting
this one to try and get all that
finalists for the Melbourne Nationals
which should be happening in July
anyone can enter but there are a whole
bunch of different rules like you can't
use certain kinds of Pokemon I'm pretty
sure the only legendary is that you can
get away with us up doors Adak yuna and
mulches but I haven't actually seen
anyone use those and all Pokemon
automatically go down to level 50 so
everyone's sort of on an even playing
field and if you have any hacks they can
detect that so you get kicked out which
shop is obviously very important for
this kind of thing
genius League a senior's Liana Moss's
League and the C Gnaeus League is 12 to
15 and masters is above that and they're
playing on Pokemon X&Y and battling it
out on a big screen and the atmosphere
is actually pretty crazy
I didn't enter myself though I think
that this is kind of inspired me too
because it's so awesome to watch well I
definitely get my sweet pass on
there are a lot of recurring Pokemon I'm
seeing a lot of Kangas cons particularly
a lot of mega Kangas cons and I spoke to
one of the runners-up with the Masters
and he said that he recommends that
people actually go online and see like
the most popular Pokemon lists and try
those out so I guess that's why there's
not a whole lot of variety there's a lot
of people probably doing that
so that's it for today it was pretty
cool it was actually a lot more exciting
than I expected but in the end the guy
who used trick room actually won with
his smoking so I guess that's not a
popular choice but definitely an
effective one and thank you to the
people who came up to me and said hi but
I guess that's it for me today you guys
I'll probably go to the Melbourne one as
well not with my iPhone so I might make
like a better quality video but this is
just like a quick globe I've been super
busy with a new job at university at the
moment so this is the best I could
really do but I'll see you guys next
time okay